Let's go. Let's go next to let's go to Lucas
from Copenhagen, one of my favorite cities in
the world. Lucas, how is Copenhagen these days?
Can you hear me? Yes, I can. Oh, cool. That's
awesome. Yeah. Well, yeah, I'm half
I'm half German, half Danish. So,
yeah, I'm a mix. So I'm I'm wondering what your
take is on the whole over thing here in Europe.
I mean, we're really in the second wave now
and all Germany is talking about like mini
lockdown or. Yeah. Oh yeah. Wave breaking
thing. I just want to know what what their
take is on that and whether your thing like
the lockdown would be would be a good choice.
Well, listen, I would I simply defer I it would
be inappropriate for me to say whether I think a
lockdown would be good. What matters is what are
the public health experts in each country say?
Spain is experiencing this. France is experiencing
this. One thing that's important to remember is we
compare what's going on in the U.S. to what's
going on in Europe is that we're getting to
wave three. Now, I know that you can say wave one
never really ended in the U.S. because we never
got below 20000 cases a day. But the point is,
we had dips and we had a spike 35000, a spike at
70000. And now we're having, you know, even 80000
cases in a day. So any compare, direct comparisons
between the U.S. and Europe? First of
all, need to be per capita. But secondly,
you guys actually suppressed the second wave all
summer. You're only getting the second wave. Now,
we're already on wave three. And so
I think that we should all be careful
to be making any direct comparisons because
Europe we're on we're one wave ahead of you
and hopefully you will never have a third wave.
That would be the hope of of taking measures now.
Yeah, yeah, I agree.
And I had another question. So have I heard
this? I saw this video from John Stossel. I don't
know if you know him. I do know. Yes. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. He's been accomplished rehearsal, right?
Yeah. And he had a video where he talked about
like a human challenge trial where volunteers
would be injected with it. You think that's
like any that would be an option or you think
that should be strictly banned by government?
Yes. So this is a big medical ethics topic, which
is if you really want to be sure a vaccine works
or a treatment works, you do a challenge
trial, which is you actually a rather than
waiting around to see how many people get
infected, you actually try to infect them.
It's a big medical ethics topic. I would
lead. Leave it to the public health experts
and medical ethicists. It wouldn't I would have
nothing substantive to add other than to say this
is not John Stossel idea. The idea of challenge
trials has been around a really long time.
Yeah, yeah, that's it.
I mean. All right. My
friend did great. By the way, have you ever
been to a place in Copenhagen called Fisk Bar?
Yes or no? No, I haven't.
All right. I recommend the fish and
chips there if you make it okay.
Well, yeah. Very good to hear. OK. All right.
Thanks so much. Great to hear from you.